Speaker 1: The next layer in the fake
elector scam is now pushing towards
criminality. You have to see this. This is
unbelievable. Newly obtained surveillance video
shows fake Trump elector escorted operatives
into Georgia County's elections office
before the voting machine breach. Let's
reset the story. The fake elector scam.
The fake elector scam was where there were
states won by Joe Biden in November of 2020.
Yes, nearly two years ago. They're still going.
Nearly two years ago, in November of 2020,
Joe Biden won certain states like Georgia and
Arizona. And Republicans came up with the idea
of just sending different electors to say,
we cast our ballots, cast our electoral votes
for Donald Trump. Even though Trump didn't win,
they would claim that he did. We now have footage
of a Republican and a Republican county official
in Georgia who was one of these fake electors
escorting two operatives working with an attorney
for Trump. Into the county's election offices
on the same day that a voting system there
was breached. Understand that these people
breached election systems. Okay. In
the surveillance video obtained by CNN.
Kathy Latham, a former Republican chairwoman
of Coffee County under criminal investigation
for posing as a fake elector in 2020, escorted
a team of pro-Trump operatives to the election
offices on January seven, 2021. That's the same
day that the voting system there was breached.
They are the ones breaching the systems.
They are the ones attempting the fraud.
Here is a report from CNN. Newly obtained video
to CNN shows a former Georgia Republican County
official escorting two operatives hired
by an attorney for former President Trump
into the county's election offices. On the same
day, a voting system there was illegally breached.
Wow. Drew Griffin has the details Drew.
What an incredible coincidence, right.
Speaker 3: Breaches of these voting machines.
Guys in swing states are under investigation
across the country. This one happened
in Coffee County, Georgia, rural county.
CNN obtained surveillance video at one of the
offices where the voting machines were breached.
And all this at the behest of one of Donald
Trump's attorneys. I want to show you right now,
this is Kathy Latham. We're showing you. She's the
former chairwoman of Coffee County. GOP already
under investigation. This woman is for posing as
one of those fake electors who signed documents
that declared Donald Trump was the winner of
the 2020 election. Latham can be seen here
escorting a team of pro-Trump operatives into the
Coffee County Elections Office, including an I.T.
specialist who was working with Trump attorney
Sidney Powell. This all happens on the same day.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine? They
have so many conspiracy theories.
They were the ones conspiring. Look at this.
Speaker 3: Putting system in that office was
illegally breached January 7th, 2021, the
day after the attack on the U.S. Capitol.
Text messages.
Speaker 1: Emails.
Speaker 3: And witness testimony from a civil
lawsuit against Georgia. Election officials have
connected Latham, that woman, to the plan to give
the group access to the elections office about
a week before this voting machine breach. That
same woman, Latham, testified before the Georgia
state legislature, along with Rudy Giuliani,
talking all about voter machine irregularities
in Coffee County. Latham's attorney told CNN.
Speaker 1: Seems some of the irregularities
were Latham herself giving people who shouldn't
have access to the voting systems, access to the
voting systems. Is anybody ever going to jail
for trying to steal the 2020 election for Trump
while they were screaming election fraud, mail in
ballot fraud, Democratic fraud. For months, they
tried to steal it. They did it in this particular
case, in broad daylight. If you didn't see the
video, it's the middle of the day when they show
up. And I'm sure that some of them would say
we had to do this stuff because the Democrats
cheated. The Democrats were cheating so bad
that we had to do it this way. But you all
in my audience didn't fall for it when Trump
started with this stuff. Late spring, early
summer, 2020, when Trump started saying,
They're going to rig it this way, they're
going to rig it that way. It's all insecure.
Many of you, dozens and dozens of you wrote to
me and said, David, allegations are confessions
with these people. Trump saying he's going to
try to steal it. That's what Trump is saying.
And of course, you were all completely
correct. Incredible. People better start
landing in prison for this. They really should.
And we're going to follow that. And as charges
develop and hopefully they will, we will tell you
whether people are actually being held accountable